[Music]
[Applause]
Chris Collinsworth Sunday Night Football
it'll be the Colts and cowboys coming up
on Sunday Night Football Chris with Mike
tariko we make it a bigger deal about
Russell Wilson with uh teammates not
attending his birthday party here Chris
this silly story
man I guess he got half of them to come
and you know if I got a tenth of them to
come to my party I'd feel good about it
if you showed up I'd feel good just the
two of us you know flashback to Dayton
and tell old stories about you know the
Glory Days and maybe playing a
one-on-one basketball game for about 30
seconds and then we would both pass out
grab a coffee somewhere is this a big
deal
uh I mean losing is a big deal right I
mean I mean let's be honest we saw it
with the Jets right I mean it doesn't
matter who the quarterback is if you're
not scoring points
I've had that look before I've had that
look where our offense is struggling and
you're running off the field because you
run right past the defensive guys right
and they're all looking at you like are
you guys ever going to score a point
today because we're out here killing
ourselves and you guys aren't aren't
holding up your share of it uh and that
happens even inside a single game
sometimes but when
when you're a free agent or you're a new
guy you get paid all the money you're
brought into the locker room he asked
them to give up their days off so he
could go present to the offense his
version of the team that they were about
to play they all showed up for all that
stuff and at some point
your offense continues to struggle it's
just a natural part of if you are the
leader of something and it's not going
well
it's gonna get ugly I mean it just it
does it's just the way that it is
running PFF when I make a bad decision I
get the guys look at me and they go what
are you doing right so it's a natural
part of leadership
um you know Russ is Mr enthusiastic all
the time and let's ride and all that
stuff and it's fantastic when you're in
the playoffs and you're going to Super
Bowls and but when it's the opposite
yeah you're gonna get you're gonna get
that look
is Kyler Murray getting that treatment
now because they're not winning that is
he a leader is he the face of this
franchise is Cliff Kingsbury the coach
you know how long is he going to be the
coach
uh the Patrick Peterson thing didn't
help right and and Patrick is a pretty
straight shooter he obviously didn't
like the way that he had to depart
Arizona there's a little bitterness
there so you you factor that in yeah but
you also factor in that
he probably told us the truth
you know I mean didn't you feel like I
mean I've known Patrick a long time and
and we always interviewed he and Larry
Fitzgerald there's always the Straight
Shooters there and Bruce Aryans when he
was there was fantastic too I was like
there there are sometimes you go into
those production meetings and you're
like uh this is going to be a zero we're
not going to get anything but with
Arizona you got the truth and so I think
that
you know I it it was probably at least
in his opinion a a true statement
um and so then you know I think
everybody has to look inside themselves
that Arizona
situation is is not in a great position
right now you know you extend the coach
and the GM and the Kyler now is going
through it you're not winning the games
and you've you've fallen off at the end
of seasons for the last few years so
yeah they they need an opposite this
year right they need you know not so
good during the regular season and then
and tear it up at the end of the year
and somehow make the playoffs what would
you do if you were running the Packers
you know we we came so close to getting
into this on the air the other night but
the game never got away you know the
game stayed close
um I I think I would talk to Aaron about
whether or not
he was
ready to sit down for a little while
um not a because he is a mess physically
we we know you know what I know about
the thumb whatever the the term was
where the bone actually tears away
probably with the ligament whatever that
is awful and you could tell that's been
bothering him I I saw him throw
non-spirals in the game before the
Eagles game in a way that I've never
seen before
um and then you know now he's got uh the
oblique injury on top of that uh and you
saw Jordan love come in and and sling it
you know and sling it so they the
Packers organization the likelihood of
them now making the playoffs
probably not great but the likelihood of
they have to make some really tough
decisions this off season whether it
pertains to Aaron whether it pertains to
Jordan love I mean they nobody knows
this decision more than the Green Bay
Packers and we we understand that with
Brad uh and it could play out that way I
mean it wouldn't even be stunning to see
Aaron Rodgers go play for the New York
Jets or the Patriots or San Francisco
you know I mean we're going to see some
weird stuff this off season like we did
last all season at the quarterback
position
um but if I I really gave you what I
thought
I think I would say for the Packers to
run it back
um and it's going to be really hard for
them to do that guys like bakyari are
going to get a ton of money if they stay
there are a lot of older veteran guys
but you know this was a weird off season
Aaron wasn't around he didn't work with
those young receivers uh there was the
pressure of trying to impress Aaron
Rodgers who was frustrated early on that
dropping the first pass of the sea there
were a lot of weird things that happened
but I do think that it's entirely
possible this defense could play up to
it next year and Aaron could play up to
it I mean you don't go from two-time MVP
to not being able to play and execute an
offense anymore and I've seen a lot of
teams have bad years and get refocused
start working harder spend more time
together and and come back the next year
and have a great year and I think that's
entirely possible if the Green Bay
Packers ran it back Sunday Night
Football to be the Colts and the Cowboys
on NBC your biggest concern about the
Cowboys heading towards the end of the
regular season in the postseason is what
you know probably if they lost one of
these receivers uh CD I think has been
fantastic and now that he's back in the
slot
um it's it's a he's a really legitimate
tough guy in their blocks does the whole
thing I really like him as a player but
the return of Michael Gallup has
probably meant the most to him that
Michael Gallup now could sit out there
at that Exposition create some deep
balls three great contested catches in
that game against the Giants uh when
Michael Gallup can handle that position
when he can force you if you want to
play single high and one-on-one on the
outside and he's going to go up and win
those jump balls that's when this team's
great but for Dak Prescott I I think the
change they made in the offense putting
him back under Center so that the hard
play action stuff off their running game
creates opportunities for big plays down
the field I thought that was the
singular sort of jumping off point uh
that kind of turned this offense around
so I don't have a lot of concerns uh
although I will say one thing I think
that the Giants even though they got
beat in that game the Giants are a
physical monster of a d-line and of a
team I mean they're they beat up this
offensive line uh to some extent on the
inside so if Tyron Smith can come back
Tyler Smith moved back into the left
guard position I think the Cowboys are
going to be well positioned late in the
year to get better and better and have a
real shot at this thing any downside to
Bringing In obj
foreign of course you know you're all
sometimes can blow up and uh but I I
like obj I I you know and then he has
the incident on the airplane what does
that mean what does that not mean I have
no idea but he's a different guy when
you talk to him than when you read his
social media I mean he is a thoughtful
sort of
God-fearing you know he's he's a really
interesting guy uh and I think the guys
on that team would really like him and
he would slide in there that's really
that third receiver position is kind of
what they're missing we saw what
happened when he was able to to draw
coverage when he was went into the Rams
organization especially when he was
really healthy at the end of the year
um
and if the Cowboys are going to win it
all I'm not sure they're winning at all
with this two and three tight end
formation as a constant you know yes
there's a change up with their running
game fantastic love it they look good
all those sort of things but there's
going to come a time in those playoffs
when they need three wide outs they can
go 11 personnel they can spread it out
and now we're gonna do CD and Michael
and now here comes
Odell as the number three
that's a different story if he's right I
mean you got to see him I I have no idea
can he run can he cut can he do the
things is it going to be a little bit
nervous on the knee after a couple
surgeries I don't know
good to talk to you as always we'll be
watching on Sunday night Chris
I love seeing you and Bobby Knight in
the same sweater in one shot that's like
a it's a cool thing thank you bud that's
uh Chris Collinsworth Sunday Night
Football with Mike Tarico in the booth
Colts Cowboys at Sunday night on NBC and
peacock